how would exercise congest the lymph?
Well, exercise is going to increase circulation.
And then increase circulation is gonna be
dilation of your blood vessels
and you'll increase capillary leakage.
You're hydrating the tissue
and your muscles are calling for energy.
So you need to increase the blood supply to the muscles.
So you're gonna have more fluid
that's gonna need to be carried away than also.
So exercise is good for lymph flow too,
but if you've had surgery
and it's blocking some of the pathways,
then that could be an issue.
So typically you want to do exercise to improve lymph flow
because you're contracting muscles
and you're moving the blood
and it's so good for every part of your body.
But if you've had surgery that is damaged,
that is put basically a dam in the stream
that could be an issue.
So it's really the change.
Let's say, well, I haven't done any exercise
that I don't normally do, then that's not it.
But if it's like, well, yeah, I was doing,
I had to go and do this.
I was working out the garden.
I was clearing this or something.
I was, I guess I did do a whole bunch
for exercise that before that could be it.
So if it isn't anything you haven't done,
if it's normal things, nothing is changed
that I wouldn't say that would be it.
But if there was a major change, that could be a factor.
If I massage every day, but also work out,
will I maintain the status quo?
Yes.
I'll let you know if something is not good.
So it's really be the change.
And you could have an infection that you, you know,
maybe it's some clinical.
So if you have a little cold or something like that,
that could be an issue.
You don't realize that they're swelling that's involved.